so first i'm going to get to a question
that i had which is
is there a correlation between any of
the characteristics of these uaps ufos
and some other characteristic for
example let's say that the
tic-tac-shaped ones are more violent or
the pyramidal shaped ones are faster
is there a classification of them and do
they have some other characteristic
associated with them
so the the the characterizations that we
have
we have seen today really is a result uh
of size believe it or not so and this is
by by no means
comprehensive but what we tend to see
are
the the smaller vehicles tend to be
uh think of a sports car are your are
your uh
saucer shaped vehicles whereas the
larger vehicles let's say a school bus
size is that of a
of a cylindrical object or roughly that
of a tic tac or even sometimes
described as a telephone pole and then
uh in shape so cylindrical and then
the the tend to be the large ones really
large ones tend to be
uh not always but almost exclusively
either triangular shape
or boomerang shape now there are some
some
some anecdotal uh if you will
reports of of large saucers as well and
some shapes looking like a dumbbell
but the three primary categories tend to
be uh that we saw in a tip were
disc shape and then you have a longer
cylindrical shape and then finally a
large
large triangular shape vehicle the
triangle vehicles are often described
as flying uh very close to the ground